all eyes are on Minnesota this weekend
thanks to college basketball's Final
Four but there's more to celebrate in
the state including a series of
innovations that have virtually ended
homelessness among military veterans
Dana join us joins us again with that
story Zdenek yeah veteran homelessness
is a problem nationwide and Minnesota is
one of just a handful of states that
seems to have actually solved it they've
used an individualized approach first
learning what factors contributed to the
situation be it mental health issues
substance abuse or just economics then
they tailor a support system to address
those issues while finding the housing
it's a model that actually could help
the general homeless population veteran
or not people don't understand how you
can get there you know they think all
life is a breeze but things happen
theresa marshall spent 13 years in the
army as an air defense artillery
specialist starting an Operation Desert
Storm I had a six month old son and a
five year old daughter and I left on her
birthday what was that like Terry very
emotional I signed up for
so you served your country I served my
country and I don't regret it she
retired in Chicago but after her husband
passed away in July of 2017
Marshall fled to the Twin Cities she
found work as a chef but wasn't able to
find a place where she could afford to
live so you were living in your car yeah
yeah
yeah I didn't want to really stay in a
shelter because of so many people or
just had a fear a visit with the
Minnesota VA changed Marshalls life when
she was told about an organization that
helps place the state's military
veterans in temporary housing what did
you think when you heard about it
terrified really was it almost the it's
too good to be true what do you want to
help
and you know why I have to give you
right exactly
Marshall wasn't alone there were just
over 1700 homeless veterans in Minnesota
in 2010 when the state decided it had
had enough how do you go about tackling
a problem like homeless veterans I think
the approach that we've taken is really
to break it down into its essential
elements Larry her key is the
Commissioner of Minnesota's VA nine
years ago his department began to
compile a registry of every veteran
living on the street in the state
working with partners like the federal
VA and numerous nonprofits they started
finding homes for veterans they all had
these resources but no one organization
could solve the problem by themselves it
took the combination of all the
organizations to be able to pull
together and to be able to come up with
the actual solution to this problem
herkie has found support at the state
level including Minnesota's new governor
Tim Walz a fellow veteran of the
National Guard it's important to fulfill
that you know no one will be left on the
battlefield no one will be left behind
to care for you know he or she who bore
the battle and that that's why we need
to do it it's about service to those
veterans and it's clear before taking
office in January walls spent 12 years
in Congress where he was the ranking
member of the House Committee on
Veterans Affairs if we're gonna fight
this fight it is gonna be big and it's
gonna be transformational with the big
key I think it probably intersected with
the military attitude that here's a
problem create courses of action and
execute the mission what is that mission
to eradicate yes this is completely zero
people say you know kind of
theoretically can you ever do that yes
you can do that we started working with
the county folks and said you have 17 of
these folks in Swift County what can we
do to help you with that and then start
aligning those resources then it became
management became one at a time you
start to place them we have an old Fort
Snelling here was an old post on the
frontier served as where the code
talkers were during World War two
there's a rich history here wall says
with some creative work at the federal
state and local level part of the fort
has been converted into transitional
housing for veterans we were up there a
few weeks ago and just a sense of pride
and it's
right next to a light rail line the
first stop is the VA hospital and
listening to these veterans say all of
these pieces came together that I can
get around I can get my health care have
a place to live now I have a job
my staff sort of talks about it as a
marathon I told them and now it's time
to do the sprint we're gonna move the
needle and we're gonna finish up with
these last 223 that need to find a home
somewhere sometimes they have nobody
else but us Sam Petersen and Rochelle
Washington help track down those
veterans as case managers for the
Minnesota assistance Council for
veterans or Mac V why is it so important
that you're here that they don't have to
come find you
sometimes they don't have the
transportation to come find us here
sometimes they don't have a phone and
the place that we know they're probably
gonna be when they go to sleep at night
is meeting them where they're at where
they're comfortable or they probably
feel safe and you know as opposed to I'm
easy builds that trust on the night we
visited the Simpson housing services
shelter Peterson met with a veteran who
opened up for the first time but tonight
we had a bit of a step forward so even
though we didn't get him moving forward
necessarily with traditional McPhee case
management as for Theresa Marshall she
found temporary housing thanks to McPhee
and moved in just a few weeks before we
met her her rent is offset by a federal
housing voucher available to veterans
and she can stay until she's able to
secure a permanent home can you imagine
where you would be if you didn't take
that leap of faith no I don't imagine
because it's almost a nightmare I have
someone to care about me now Sam
Peterson who's that caseworker from a
fee that we spent time with told us the
veteran that opened up to him the night
we were with him he's actually seen him
at the VA is community resource and
referral center and that's another step
forward to trying to find housing for
him it's all a process and again it's
that individualized approach
that number now is down to 223 homeless
veterans that's all from where they
started it's really a huge step forward
it's amazing progress tanta what they're
doing it just in a remarkable program
kudos to the caseworkers and it seems so
obvious right yes figure out what the
problems are what they need and you give
it to him yeah it's just easier said
than done and remember that when it's
not the veteran population it gets a
little bit trickier you can't do this
exactly across the board you don't have
a federal housing voucher that you can
do you don't have some of the assistance
that veterans are getting but it's
certainly certain things that they can
look at Dana you have earned your keep
this week that's how amazing